I'm joined today by Steve Horowitz who
is the Charles a Dana professor of
economics at st. Lawrence University and
currently a visiting scholar at the John
H Snyder Institute for entrepreneurship
and free enterprise at Ball State
University it's so great to talk to you
you have this fascinating article about
uh how trickle-down economics isn't a
thing and when I read the title alone I
thought oh that that's fantastic
Steve thinks that the concept of
trickle-down economics is bogus but then
upon reading more about your views it
turns out that what you really mean is
that there are no serious economists who
use the term and say that there is such
a thing as trickling down and I I want
to open it up to you to sort of make
that case but the way I'm approaching it
is isn't this sort of semantics we're
talking about supply-side economics
you're just saying that name is not
something economists use well I think
I'm saying two things I think that's one
thing right that that professional
economists don't use that phrase that
phrase is one of those classic ones
that's invented by the critics of a
position to describe it but the second
thing I'm saying is that that the idea
that seems to be in the critics mind of
trickle-down economics the idea that
somehow if we give things to the rich in
particular we cut their taxes or we
favor them with subsidies or something
like that that somehow making the rich
richer or letting the rich be rich will
quote trickle-down and improve the lives
of the poor I think that's not true
either no no in other words no economist
should say no there's almost no
economists who believe that uh you
thought there's almost obviously you can
find an economist to please almost
anything but no but very few economists
believe that that's not what I think uh
no one thinks that's that's how the
economy grows is by sort giving things
to rich people and somehow they
magically make their way down to
everybody else well no but it's not
usually claimed as magic right I mean
that though the way that a supply-side
ER might talk through the logic is okay
if you reduce taxes on the very rich
they now have more money and since they
run the businesses they'll now be
encouraged because they'll have more
money to pour more money into their
business
that means in part hiring people
presumably people in the lower middle or
lower middle classes and that's going to
create jobs it's going to circulate more
money into the economy isn't that sort
of the idea I it might be but there's so
many fallacies wrapped up in that story
that's all that yeah okay so I do think
first of all I don't see any serious
economists arguing that we want to just
give tax breaks to the very rich but
most people supply siders even would say
we want to cut taxes across the board
that that was the Kemp Roth cuts in the
Reagan years regular so if the idea is
when we free up the economy in general
across-the-board freer economies produce
more wealth and that wealth works its
way across the entire economy so it's
not that it's this idea that somehow if
we favor the rich in particular they'll
do all these things but things that you
described which again I think that
there's problems there too uh that that
it's not just a matter of the rich sort
of if they have more money they'll do
all these things you need to have an
economy that's driven by
entrepreneurship and free enterprise
that's what makes wealth spread to
everyone uh and as I argue in that piece
it's hardly a trickle historically it's
been a flood when we have when we have
genuinely free enterprise don't you
think though that you could actually
make the case of it so I think we both
agree that just giving tax cuts to the
rich is not the way to stimulate an
economy most effectively and you sort of
referred to the idea of across-the-board
tax cuts but it's it's pretty widely
documented that $1 in tax cut does not
have the same impact by giving it to
someone at the very top of the income
range than someone who is towards the
bottom and and the concept of a marginal
propensity to consume sort of
illuminates this pretty clearly if you
earn twenty thousand dollars a year and
you have an extra dollar now that you're
not paying in taxes there's a much
higher chance that you need that dollar
for your day-to-day subsistence and will
spend it
in a way that it will have an economic
multiplier that would far exceed if
someone earns three hundred thousand
dollars a year and now they have one
extra dollar the odds that the three
hundred thousand dollar earner needs
that extra dollar rather than just
sticking it in a bank account is far
lower isn't it except again couple
problems with that argument first of all
it's just sticking it in a bank account
is good thing put in the bank account
that becomes savings that gets to
transfer to other to borrowers that
becomes investment that creates capital
yet but at a far smaller degree the the
economic multiplier of that dollar is
far smaller than someone saying I'm
gonna go to my local grocery store buy
an extra dollar of food no I don't think
that's true in fact I mean economies the
health of economies are not driven by
consumption if they were right why don't
we just print up a bunch bunch of
dollars hand them out to people on the
street let them buy stuff with it right
it's not about consumption it's about
the ability to produce and create
hopefully create value that's why I mean
I fact I think part of the argument here
is we get focused on tax cuts right and
I think the real issues in many ways are
about the regulatory burden and and and
and the way in which the regulatory
state cuts off opportunity makes it
difficult for people to innovate and put
new ideas into practice and that by the
way harms not just the wealthy but also
the poor who have who for whom the
limits on their opportunities are very
great well but this all to some degree
that's true to some degree but I I think
I mean would you would you characterize
your views as a libertarian on economics
broadly speaking out yep I'm perfectly
comfortable with that word so begin to
that a little I mean you know I've
spoken to libertarians that I would sort
of generally characterized as reasonable
operating on this planet and then I've
talked to libertarians who believe that
any government apparatus of regulation
or or revenue collection or anything
whatsoever is inherently slavery can you
give us a sense of sort of where in that
you are well look I wouldn't my view is
that government which governs least as
much as possible governs best how far we
can go with that I think is an open and
interesting question that's debated all
the time among libertarians and others
but for me I'm concerned about the
low-hanging fruit right if we want to
talk about improving the lives of the
least well off let's talk about say
ending occupational licensing let's talk
about competition in the school system
let's talk about ending the war on drugs
let's talk about not raising the minimum
wage
just not eliminating it all together and
so again for me I'm not the debate over
how small can government go isn't all
that interesting to me when there's all
these very reasonable steps we can take
in the mean time that that I think will
benefit will help the very people who
need it the most well you know other
libertarians who go off debate who
should build the roads or whether
taxation staff that's that's fine and
dandy and interesting if you've had a
few beers but we really want to move the
lives of of real people who need their
lives improving let's talk about these
other kinds of things that that where we
know we can get government out of the
picture in some ways that will really
help well all those lines I mean let's
let's talk a little bit about health
insurance right I mean I think that as I
view 2016 earth or or at least the
United States uh the the case for a free
market health insurance for-profit
system seems to be increasingly not
unethical and immoral but but also just
completely unworkable and I'm of the
mindset that I want uh I want capitalism
I'm into a sort of properly regulated
capitalism but I think that there are
certain areas of our lives which
particularly when we consider the
advancements and and sort of the size
and scope of our economy and we can
focus on the US for now I just don't
need to be nor are we on average best
served by the profit motive and for me
health insurance is one of those aspects
right when we look at other countries
that don't have this thing called
medical bankruptcy and the more I study
this the more I'm convinced that it's
not even an issue of to what degree
should we allow health insurance
companies to do with the what that what
they want I just don't believe that
health insurance should be under the
umbrella of businesses you can make
money from but tell me how how I'm wrong
well a couple things first of all let's
let's recognize it the US health care
system as it stands right now is like
the worst of all possible world it's the
worst of the market and worst of
government together and I'm not going to
defend the status quo by any means and
the whole reason we're in this mess is
because we tried to do government
stepped in and tried to do certain kinds
of things going back to World War two
that created this mess more important
though without so we can talk about the
profit motive but it's not them the
thing about
profit is it's not just a motivator it's
not just incentives it also is a signal
that tells us where resources need to be
allocated when we take the profit motive
out of any industry and that includes
healthcare right we simply don't we have
no way of knowing where the value is
what people want how many resources
should be valued elsewhere right you can
hear people there's people who owe its
you know government health care is a
form of socialism arts too creeping
socialism mean there's some sense in
which that's that's an over-the-top
claim but if there's a truth to it in
the sense that to the degree we
eliminate the profit motive and
eliminate markets we will face the same
kinds of problems at a smaller scale
that socialist economies face when they
limited eliminated those things overall
I'm not just about that guy I mean also
to pick up on one aspect of that if you
say the that there's a sort of common
interest in raising the average health
status of our country and everyone who's
in it and we're going to sort of
socialize what that costs and say you
know right now what we sort of pay for
it either way there are some people who
pay these outrageously high premiums for
mediocre care there are people who can't
afford any coverage and they're using
the emergency room as their primary care
and that's being averaged into what
people pay anyway up what if we said hey
listen we want a healthy 340 million
people so that they can go out there and
be the best teachers they can be and
build the best businesses that they can
and be as productive as possible at work
and we're going to say let's look at
what this would cost in total and make
sure that nobody goes without why is
that bad why would it be bad to have
that approach it it sounds great you
just can't work right I mean I'm all in
favor of the goal of making people
healthier look let me take the media
analogy suppose we said we want 340
million well fed you know people who eat
nutritious food all the time
therefore we should turn the whole
operation over to government and take
the profit motive out of the food
industry well guess what we've tried
that around the world it leads to famine
and disaster okay well you make you may
be right about that you may be right
that there are examples where it hasn't
worked but I think that the example
you're pointing to which is hey what if
we just decided nobody's going to go
hungry anymore if you actually look at
the total number of calories that are
produced and the total number of
that are necessary for everybody to be
well-fed we have fundamentally a
distribution issue with regard to hunger
we already produce more than enough food
for nobody to be hungry and I think that
that's whether it's government or
private industry there's no will to fix
that but it's quite fixable but but see
but you're falling for the same sort of
synaptic what what hi called fatal could
see here right to sort of say oh well
there's a problem we know how to fix it
from the top down if we just pull these
levers and push these buttons and move
things around we'll do it it's more
complicated than that and I think when
we look at you can say it's a
distribution problem we have a screwed
up food system to some degree to with
artificial subsidies for everything from
sugar to crops to all these sorts of
things right
but what we know over the long run is
that markets have made it possible to
feed most not all and not all as well as
we'd like seven billion people on the
planet in a way that 200 years ago with
1 billion a much higher percentage of
those folks were malnourished
we know markets do this and we know
where we've limited markets they don't
work what I'd like to see with
healthcare is more not the status quo we
have in the US which is a mess and that
the you know that's why we see the
problems you've identified but if we can
generate more market competition real
market competition in that process I
think that we can actually produce
better outcomes them than we have can we
ensure all 340 million Americans the
same level of health is the best people
do know but that's that touches because
resources are scarce right it's wishful
thinking to think that we can do a lot
better than than we are I think that and
we don't really have time to get into
this now because I have one other thing
I want to touch base on but Sir I think
one of the one of the most distracting
notions that currently is involved in
these issues of sort of economics that
we're talking about whose responsibility
profit motive or not is and over over uh
a disproportionate focus on scarcity
where it increasingly is not actually
existing as good as technology continues
to improve I I'm guessing you disagree
but will maybe save that for a different
day yeah well what I wanted to ask about
Steve was that's a whole session
it's a whole session yeah when you look
at we have an election next week when
you look at Trump and Clinton really the
only two people who have a shot at this
thing from a libertarian economics
perspective uh what what's your what's
your view I mean I went when you look at
the side
as of the infrastructure spending Trump
wants which is far bigger than Clinton I
don't know that Trump is actually the
guy for a libertarian economist like you
I was asked this question a talk I gave
earlier this week to give them a letter
grade if they were in my class and I'll
repeat what I answered then Trump gets
an F the man is completely ignorant of
economics it's all about Trump he thinks
he's running for CEO of the country
countries don't work like that economies
don't work like that Trump would be an
unmitigated disaster Hillary's pretty
close to an F the only reason I'll give
her the MOT the pass and would admit
that on those grounds she's better is
the sort of what we've heard recently
that what she tends to say in private is
oftentimes what better than what she
says in public and I don't think she's
as ignorant and I don't think Jesus or
chief Trump has surrounded himself with
some pretty bad folks - and Trump sort
of inability to be anything but a
narcissist I think and his willingness
to cut off international trade even more
severely than Clinton on her worst day
sense I think is a huge problem not just
to the US but elsewhere so yeah on those
grounds alone I think you know Hillary's
economics is marginally less disastrous
than Trump's all right Steve Horowitz
Charles a Dana professor of economics at
st. Lawrence University visiting scholar
at UH the John H Snyder Institute for
entrepreneurship and free enterprise at
Ball State University thanks a lot for
talking about this I think our audience
will enjoy it my pleasure thanks for
having me day